hey guys how's it going so today's been
a really exciting day because the new
emojis have now finally been released on
the new iOS update 8.3 and I was driving
at the time when it happened so my
sister and I had to pull over to a
Barney's Beanery which is a little
restaurant you need to find a place that
has Wi-Fi when you don't faith emojis
immediately and our initial reaction
when we opened up the emoji tab to see
all the new emojis was just like
perhaps I should find an emoji to
properly display my emoji reaction so
who owned you first so cuz you guys
sorry the lighting keeps changing
because the Sun is about to go down so
here are all of the new emojis it's kind
of out of hand I mean how am I ever
gonna find the pool emoji how am I ever
gonna find the poo emoji in emergencies
tell me no make sure we can see this cuz
I've got a privacy screen on so if I
turn it lately you will be able to see
my screen anymore it's magic and uh and
pardon all of my snapchat updates it's
because you guys snapped me a lot of
photos so so some of the emojis have
other sets of emojis inside of them so
essentially you hold it down you can
choose whichever emoji you would like
and you click it and yeah that's it I
mean that's
it's really it but there's so many of
them I mean you can even change this
skin tone of the baby baby emoji B which
was once brunette girl she can now I'm a
little disappointed though because uh
not that I would ever ever ever use this
emoji but I thought they were supposed
to be a middle finger emoji and judging
by the looks of me scrolling through
here I do not see it where is it it is
not here it's probably for the better
because that's just not a nice thing to
do
do you guys have a favorite emoji
because mine's obviously the pool emoji
which is not readily available where are
you where's the pool emoji where is the
poo emoji cell is in under so they've
got them now separated into categories
frequently used you've got people okay
where the houseboaters thank god sorry
nature
food and drink celebration what is that
still no black heart it's really
unfortunate activity gravel in places
objects and symbols I thought the new
Lodhi update was going to change my life
I really thought it was going to and now
it's only complicating my life because
what if I send one of my friends an
emoji who is not updated to the latest
iOS or what if I send them on a mochi to
the web that is not compatible with
other emoji viewing things I don't know
this is really is quite a dilemma let me
know what you guys think of the new
emojis either way I guess shut up I'm
not trying to talk to you Siri you'll
try and talk to me I don't want to talk
to you that's it she want to show you
guys the new emoji also I relearned show
you my shirt it's a little wrinkled
because I had it in my suitcase
this is an official iJustine
throwbackthursday t-shirt that I made
with represent calm /i Justine I wanted
to release this t-shirt before my new
book came out so if you guys have seen
cover then you might have already seen
it but this is only available for a
couple more days if you guys want to get
it before it's gone represent comm slash
iJustine I'm really excited stay tuned
for a book announcement video tomorrow
I'm really excited
also be at Coachella this weekend so if
any of you guys are there I'll be
looking for you guys and there's so much
stuff coming up and I'm so excited to
bring you guys along for the ride and
thankfully I will have some more time to
actually make some more videos and do
some gaming videos I'm just really
excited to be home I love my home this
lighting sucks my other camera battery
died and the Sun is going down you're
ruining my shot peace out
emojis you know